hey what's up everyone its Warren with a
brand new update on the Avengers in-game
official trailer 2 as I said a few
videos ago Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios did come out and say that
we would be getting an official trailer
2 for Avengers in game and as I also
mentioned in my last video trailer track
calm a website that tracks wind trailers
are going to come out reported that we
should be getting the next Avengers in
game official trailer sometime between
March 11th and March 21st
however they have now reported a new
timeline due to some information that
they have learned they are now reporting
that the trailer should come out
sometime between March 25th and April
4th this aligns with a big rumor going
around that we should get the Avengers
in game's second trailer on April 2nd
however this is just a rumor for now
there is good news however to the date
range being pushed back as I mentioned
in my previous trailer update video
Empire Magazine is going to be posting
exclusive Avengers in-game content on
March 21st and now we have also learned
that Entertainment Weekly will be
posting exclusive Avengers in-game
content as well the day after Empire
magazine does which will be March 22nd
so although it's looking like we won't
get the Avengers in-game trailer to that
week we will be getting some exclusive
content for Avengers in game again Kevin
Feige has confirmed that we will be
getting a full second official trailer
for Avengers in game not a TV spot and
not 30 seconds of footage so the second
trailer is coming and as soon as I find
out more information about it I will let
you all know let me know what you're
excited to get a look at when the
Entertainment Weekly and Empire
exclusives come out and when this second
official Avengers and game trailer
releases let me know in the comments
down below and again a reminder about my
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win 5 imax tickets all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Avengers in game including when that
next trailer is going to drop and all
thanks Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]